one of the
misconceptions about inflation is that
it is only driven by monetary policy
obviously monetary policy has a big
effect but you recently wrote a piece
about fiscal driven inflation maybe you
could expand on that a little bit and
explain why is the fiscal component so
important given the inflation we're
seeing right now
sure so a big theme i've had actually
for a couple years now is that the
inflation that we're going to get which
which now we have is in large part
driven by fiscal spending and the
difference you know for for people that
that don't know the difference monetary
policy is like what the central bank
does it's like what are interest rates
going to be are they doing quantitative
easing or quantitative tightening that
sort of thing whereas fiscal policy uh
is that basically about taxing and
spending by uh you know congress and the
president um
and especially when you get extreme
fiscal policy uh like you know unusually
large multi-trillion dollar deficits um
that that actually puts money out of the
broad money supply and so if you look
back at say the 2008 crisis for example
um there was a large monetary response
so we saw the the base money go up quite
a bit but most most of that just stayed
in the banking system it didn't actually
really circulate to the general public
it's not like you and me got checks sent
to us uh that we can then use to buy
things right so there would it's not
like people had more purchasing power
there's there was not a realistic
version of more money chasing the same
goods whereas what we saw in the 2020
response uh was in addition to the
monetary response we also had things
like helicopter money um ppp loans that
turn into grants um you know uh tax
basically just tax cuts that are not uh
offset by
anything else um and so that was a large
injection directly to people's bank
accounts uh in different ways we also
saw corporate bailouts for example
and so in that type of environment you
actually have a broad money supply
increase there's actually more money
that people can control chasing the same
number of goods and services and of
course the monetary policy is still
relevant because they're printing money
to buy the bonds that is enabling the
physical expenditure uh because if they
try to just issue trillion dollars of
bonds
um they'd have problems with like
liquidity like there wouldn't be enough
buyers showing up to buy those
treasuries
and so the the central banks are
monetizing that fiscal um so it's really
that that blend of monetary policy and
physical together as well as of course
real world constraints that you've run
into right so the fact that we had under
invested in you know kind of physical
goods like you know oil capex and things
like that for a few years was it was the
also the supply side of this whole
inflation thing is it fair to break down
the most simplistic
analysis being monetary policy drives
liquidity into the financial system but
fiscal policy drives liquidity into the
hands of people and because we got both
in 2020 the monetary policy drove the
asset bubble and the fiscal policy drove
the inflation so kind of all
items went up in price some of them were
investment assets some of them were
consumer goods and services is that a
way to break it down or could the fiscal
policy actually have also had an impact
on the asset prices going up as well
i think you described it well but i
would say that that fiscal impacts both
so i think that i think that monetary
policy you know specifically qe putting
putting liquidity into the system is is
generally pretty good for financial
assets
uh whereas uh fiscal policy is is is
basically you know consumer price
inflation uh as well as you know because
that consumer price inflation resulting
in more revenue and and things like that
for various businesses at least in
nominal terms
it's also generally good for asset
prices and nominal terms
whether it's in real terms is another
story and a good example of this is is
japan because if you look at their qe i
mean they did more qe as a percentage of
their gdp than like any other major
country i mean they have you know their
balance sheets over 100 percent of their
gdp whereas united states it's like you
know under 40 percent and they just it
looks like a weimar charter look at
their at their base money but because it
wasn't combined with huge fiscal
expenditures i mean their their broad
money supply actually went up pretty
slowly this whole time and if you look
at japan so they they're well known for
like their 30-year bear market where
their equities are still literally like
like cheaper than they were uh in the
beginning of the 90s
but that wasn't like a sideways market i
mean you had a a couple decades of
downturn and then starting around 2012
you japan actually had a pretty strong
equity bull market it was like one of
the you know outside of the us it was
one of the better performing equity
markets over the past decade and that's
that's specifically when their qe
started really ramping up uh in 2012
they started printing a ton of money in
2012 they never really stopped uh and
that included for them unlike the fed
buying equities and so if you look at
japanese equities from 2012 you look at
their qe from 2012 uh there's a pretty
strong correlation with that being very
good for their equity market um but it
wasn't consumer price inflationary for
japan because again it wasn't combined
with things like helicopter money or
things like that